[Applause]
i'm like tongue-tied excited
because i love funny women i i just i
think that you're like sexy medicine
okay so you have this new movie coming
out uh blithe spirit and i was watching
it over the weekend and it is a trip
outside of our homes that we're all
stuck in it's in a beautiful landscape
with beautiful costumes it harkens back
to like
a time that's like part 80s part 30s you
know it's
it's so fantastic to be in a world like
this
why did you guys want to make this movie
well okay i'm going to speak because
leslie i don't okay um i was so
attracted to this material because it's
null coward and the wit and word
wordplay of that 1940s plays he wrote
was so
uh influential when i was you know a
young actor and also the dialect is
something different for me um you have
to speak so quickly and crisply and um
and uh yeah it was just it's a different
style of comedy it's kind of a softer uh
it's it's a lot of kind of like um
hijinks and physical comedy and
slapstick and uh it's it's you know from
a different era and there was something
very charming about that uh from i'm
used to reading kind of modern comedy so
it was a nice throwback to the good old
days
yeah it is it's very like it's a cl it
feels like a really classic piece and
it's just a wonderful world to be living
in and
um
leslie you know when you come onto the
scene like it's also just like isla
fisher you know and you i want to just
be in between the bread of that sandwich
i don't want to have to choose
is that a normal reaction
i wish you were
i wish you were
it would be so much more fun
hi dre
oh leslie i'm so happy to see you and
i'm so happy to see you too
i mean this is great
this is weird but it's great it's it's
i'm looking at the screen and i'm but
i'm really happy to be here and happy to
see you i know normally we would all see
each other like out in the world and we
all have friends in common isla you and
i have been on double dates like
leslie i remember meeting your daughter
maude when she was the tiniest little
baby
and judd was maybe finishing a polish on
like the wedding singer script uh-huh
yep uh-huh that's right
i know
we all go way back
we do and yet
even though i know you both leslie i've
taken you aside and been like look i
just need to talk to you about
the baller comedy chops that you just
did in 40 year old virgin you played a
role that is so iconic it's going to
stand the test of comedy time forever
i think that women in comedy for me is
my preferred medicine in life
it's true and you know what
i wonder do you guys need to laugh in
life too because you're both married to
extremely funny men who put so much good
comedy out into the world i mean sasha
bear and cohen and judd apatow can we
think of two men who have been a bigger
gift to all of us in the
we need to laugh and look at life kind
of way so you guys
you say sasha's sasha is funny at home
right
judd is not funny at home
[Laughter]
he's a nice person but he's not going
around being funny all day i but i wish
he i wish he was but but sasha is funny
at home he just
like yeah i mean obviously there are
serious moments it's like you know
running you know having little tiny
people and trying to manage schedules
and you know but uh overall yeah i laugh
i definitely yes i think comedy gets us
through particularly a time like now
it's like if you can't and i personally
think there's no
inappropriate time for comedy i think if
you can i mean obviously there are
inappropriate things that one can can
say within that sentence but i do think
that like it's just there or there's
always time to have like some injection
of relief from whatever we're going
through it's it's fantastic it's what
bind i'm a big fan of comedy
i am too
and another thing i would be a really
big fan of is seeing leslie in a pair of
roller skates
um is this true that you might have
taken up um the quads while being in the
quarantine
i did
i did well it was on election day i was
oh there's yeah there's mud on the left
inside
um oh my god
i i'm i know i'm even i can do all kinds
of little tricks now i've been working
at it it's so much fun you look so
effortless and cool and i'm just
you know what you are effortless and
cool leslie and i let you guys you're
just
i was so excited to talk to you um
because i am on the feeder of what you
both put out into the world you and your
whole families really you know and i've
really come to reappreciate
entertainment i feel like we need it now
more than ever
so and we appreciate you
[Music]
you